bah Nana to a no news it is officially
Fox's most streamed summer series debut
ever begin no surprise there but what is
a surprise how much the cast got paid to
do it being on a show where you get paid
a gazillion dollars it wasn't at the
zillions of dollars not zillions then
and certainly not now according to a new
report is the Beverly Hills cast making
peach-pit pennies more like 70 grand an
episode per The Hollywood Reporter or
four hundred and twenty thousand total
for the six episodes series that's on
par with what actors reportedly get on a
freshman series like season one of this
is us not a hit show that lasted ten
seasons 32 episodes a year I sign on to
the project I could direct the pilot
Jason directs next week's episode so he
does get more 46,000 more but that's the
minimum pay any director would get Tory
and Jenny as co-creators they each
reportedly pull in about double that for
the series there's money to be made here
I was definitely worried from from the
beginning like this is not gonna work
they're not gonna like it
oh they like it eh 902 a know is Fox's
best summer scripted return in nearly a
decade the network had no comment on the
salary report which doesn't mention how
much cash they all make executive
producing guys are all producers on this
show correct I think we're learning
everyday how much input we actually you
know there are a lot of cooks in the
kitchen but it's not Will & Grace money
for their revival each cast members
reportedly making three hundred and
fifty thousand in Episode five times
more than the crew from West Bev
[Music]